my most famous Wine Library story is a
woman in Bergen County getting a
delivery to the wrong place of Beringer
white zimpel which is $3 a bottle a $36
case of wine misdelivered she calls and
complains it's in December with bad
weather it's one of the busiest days in
the store her son called and was really
complaining cuz she was really upset cuz
she needed her bearinger white zidel for
the holidays she was elderly in her 90s
and I knew that it was an opportunity
for me to show that customer over
everything no matter what kind of
customer and I took a case of Beringer
from the wehouse downstairs threw it in
my car drove to Bergen County delivered
a tour and came back missed an hour and
a half lost tens of thousands of dollars
in Revenue potential during that time
but it became a story that became
connective tissue for my
company